when i was a child my brother would tell
me a bedtime story about the man who
murdered our father worst bedtime story
ever yo grace i know my brother like you
knew your sister daenerys targaryen
would be the queen of all the kingdoms
that tv sins mainly because she has
dragons in i'm not [ __ ] with the
dragon but also because of this line of
dialogue do you want me to apologize i
won't rejected tv since slogan somehow
makes its way into the episode the
things we do for love if bran is doing a
callback to the first episode of season
one it would have been more accurate to
say the things you do for love but since
i'm pretty sure this is reference to the
english rock band 10 cc i'd be remiss if
i didn't critique his complete lack of
melody while delivering this lyric this
drab interior just because the color
palette is appropriate for the story and
setting doesn't make it any less of a
sin i suspect one of you will be wearing
this before it's all over i mean
probably not the exact thing tyrion is
wearing although i'd weirdly like to see
jorah in one of tyrion's outfits now i
will take no questions at this time show
wants us to believe that gendry is doing
work here but aside from looking
contemptuously at someone actually doing
work and touching everything once all
he's done is a little polite hammering
and quenched to steal well before he has
made anything resembling a weapon it's
not so much that they built the thirst
trap it's all the run time they're
wasting on the foreplay how many few
what are they like really bad even a
smith's apprentice can do better than
really bad thank you arya thought i was
gonna have to send these non-answers
death that's what they're like never
mind i still do i'm something else now
what is when your character has long an
interesting multi-season arc that seems
to be setting you up for a huge payoff
but ultimately the most memorable things
you do are giving someone a
life-changing seizure and telling your
cousin that he's banging his aunt this
guy is wearing a backpack not a pack
fastened to his back just a modern-day
backpack together again episode reminds
us we never got a jamie and tyrion
spin-off sitcom where they're forced to
be roommates because of the new tax laws
passed in braavos but this sparks an
idea to form a ban and they get to play
sets at the local bar where they meet an
unruly but funnily group of [ __ ]
public displays of saliva she lying
about the baby too the young in the game
of throneless girls around my
all right i'll admit this is a line we
all laughed at in season one but the
show acts like this is a catchphrase and
not something he said to get out of a
jam that one time i'm sure i'll feel
some satisfaction denying her that
pleasure sharden freuder i came to
winterfell because i'm not the fight i
used to be because he's the man with the
golden hand
when i heard you'd named tyrion your
hand it broke my heart game of skips i
was hoping we could speak alone it's not
only that i hate how much this episode
is made up of long-winded conversations
it's also that i hate how much every
conversation is trying to set up
something instead of giving us any kind
of closure on the multitude of
storylines that are finally converging
now i'm here half a world away this
reminds me misho has done a piss-poor
job of explaining the size of this dyson
sphere i'm here because i love your
brother oh you
then i survived the battle of the
baskets reminding me that i'd much
rather be rolling commercials on that
episode instead of watching this one
which where should i go either this is a
heavy-handed reference to shireen
baratheon or the show thinks sir davos
is incapable of being an empathetic
father figure to children without facial
scars all right i'll defend the crypt
then show has four episodes left after
this one and it's wasting precious time
on scenes like this i don't get why fans
complained but i think they may have
been complaining about the wrong things
oh wow we're getting a heartfelt reunion
of you know these people why are there
so many names to keep up with we have
limited mental space here my friend has
five kids and he gave up on remembering
their names after child three we had to
travel around them to get here so they
took a longer route but still arrived
before the night king joe thinks the
white walkers are making time to stop
and smell the corpses show forgets that
we as viewers have been preparing for
this battle for seven seasons and
doesn't think that we might find it
absurd that our protagonists have waited
for the final few hours before the
battle to form a plan they follow his
command if he falls getting to him may
be our best chance this band of heroes
rest their entire plan on this single
theory i don't even come up with a
contingency plan just in case the death
star-sized plot convenience turns out
not to be true he'll never expose
himself preposterous this is hbo what
does he want an endless knight mixing up
your agatha christie with your george rr
martin it's easier to do than you think
game of thrones is essentially and then
there were none with dragons and incest
he wants to erase this world and i am
its memory even if i for the moment
disregard how much i believe this
motivation to be complete bullsh their
plan still hinges on the night king
trying to snuff out bran mid-battle and
considering he's waited seven seasons to
come south of the wall at all it's fair
to assume he's a patient man your
memories don't come from books no one's
memory comes from a book unless the
memories about the time you were reading
a book but even then it didn't really
come from a book as much as it is about
a book if i wanted to erase the world of
man i'd start with you is that a is that
a compliment i took this castle from you
let me defend you now using the reason
someone shouldn't trust you is the
reason that they should trust you
survive the fist of the first man the
third fourth in fifth men are when it
really becomes a test of wills it wasn't
so simple i was sleeping with my sister
and you had one friend in the world
who was sleeping with his sister this
might be the most [ __ ] up explanation
of simplicity in the history of tv and
film but nikolai coster waldow pulls it
off so beautifully i think he deserves
the tip of the sinn hat you want some of
this piss thank you my lord i don't
think that's wise getting grog blocked
that's how i got so strong
giant's milk
torment is the best part of this episode
but also tormund is the best part of
this episode come on tormund you've got
to turn the horn 90 degrees when you get
to the bottom or the air bubbles will
rise and cause the contents to spill out
someone didn't study their beer fest i
think we might live you still might but
you'd had a better shot at survival if
you'd stop seeing who can get alcohol
poisoning the fastest a few hours before
the battle commences but you do you
winterfell defenders women can't be
nights why not tradition
tradition seriously how is [ __ ]
tormund the voice of logic in this
episode arise brienne of a knight of the
seven kingdoms roll commercials my name
my real name is aegon targaryen thinking
this reveal that we all knew was coming
could somehow make up for this episode
being boring as shh
will you shut up
i know death he's got many faces i'd
like to take his his face off
stay alive no matter what occurs i will
find you
my lord we're not soldiers nothing for
you if i wanted to erase the world of
man i'd start with you this isn't about
you i stole a considerable number of
books from the citadel library survive
the fist of the first man you want me on
that wall you need me on that wall you
lost the client there are less air
fishing lodges no repercussions from
lewiston i'm done agreeing
wholemongering is still an option for
you would that
it were so simple what do we have here
what's up nine my nipples it's freezing
out there